[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette année c'est rose l'année derre
c'était bleu chaque année on change on
va offrir aux artistes un pack de 18
bombes où ils vont avoir du turquoise du
jaune et du gris t des gamme
[Musique]
élargie l'objectif de ce festival c'est
d'ouvrir les cultures au plus grand
nombre c'est pour ça que sur chaque
activité qu'on propose que ce soit la
danse le basket le graffiti le diging le
skateboard le parcours c'est de faire
des
[Musique]
initiations et les après-midis c'est
plutôt les démonstrations les
compétitions où là du coup c'est plus
les artistes et les les compétiteurs
professionnels qui vont s'affronter et
on a aussi une exposition 100 % run
colors avec les artistes qui seront
présents pendant le weekend pour peindre
sur les
murs
on a la chance d'accueillir une
délégation de Diego Suarez trois jeunes
de Diego qui dansent qui
peignent c'est vraiment une opportunité
de voir comment ça se passe comment ça
s'organise voilà quoi c'est on se sent
bien on est à côté c'est l'île
[Musique]
voisine l'ensemble du festival est
gratuit et ouvert à tout le monde samedi
11 et dimanche 12 novembre à Saint-Louis
à l'étend du
[Musique]
GO